بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما
بعد فالكلام موصول حول
الايه السابع عشره من سوره
الرعد وهي قوله تعى
انزل من السماء ماء فسالت اوديه
بقدرها فاحتمل السيل زبدا
الرابيه ومما يوقدون عليه في النار ابتغاء
حليه او متاع زبد مثله كذلك يضرب الله
الحق والباطل فاما الزبد فيذهب جفاء واما
ما ينفع الناس فيمكث في الارض كذلك يضرب
الله
الامثال
ف في هذين
المثلين في المثل
الاول الذي ضربه الله سبحانه
وتعالى لاثر القران على قلوب
الناس انزل من السماء ماء
اي وكذلك انزل من السماء
وحيا فسالت
اوديه
والوادي هنا الذي
يسيل بهذا
الماء
ف تمثيل لقلوب
الناس التي
تستقبل هذا الوحي
المبارك يقول تعالى فاحتمل السيل زبد
الرابيه وهذا
الزبد
نتيجه الشهوات والشبهات
ا العلقه بقلب هذا
الانسان فان الوحي ينظف ويحمل هذا
الزبد يقول تعالى في مثال اخر ومما يوقدون
عليه في النار ابتغاء حليه او متاع زبد
مثله الناس
معادن عائشه رضي الله عنها في الصحيحين
تروي لنا ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
الناس معادن كمعادن الذهب
والفضه خياركم في الاسلام خيارهم في
الجاهليه اذا فقهوا او اذا
فقهوا وال
هو العلم مع التطبيق العمل بهذا المعلوم
عن الله سبحانه وتعالى في كتاب الله اذا
الناس
معاد والله سبحانه وتعالى يبتلي الناس كل
على حسب
ايمانه
ف لا يزداد بذلك الا
تطهيرا ونسال الله تعالى
ان يجعلنا ممن اذا ابتلوا
صبروا يقول تعالى زبد مثله اي زبد مثل
الزبد الماضي
تصويره وذلك الذي يكون
على
السيل فهذان
الزبان يتشابهان
الا ان السبب يختلف
احدهما السبب الماء والاخر السبب
النار وكذلك الوحي
والابتلاء فحين نزول الوحي على
القلب استقبال القلب
للوحي فانه يكون
صراع هذا
الصراع يكون داخلي وخارجي بين
الناس بين الشخص ونفسه نفسه الاماره
بالسوء
والشيطان نفسه تثير عليه والشهوات
والشبهات
تظهر ويبتدئ الانسان يشعر بالضيق ويشعر
بالحرج الا ان هذا زبت يزول سرعان ما
يزول
ولنتذكر اول نزول الوحي على النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم اول ما نزل الوحي
عليه لم يعد ويرجع الى خديجه رضي الله
عنها يتهلل وجهه فرحا وانما رجع يقول
دثروني دثروني وصبوا علي من
الماء وقال لخديجه اني خشيت على نفسي يعني
الموت او
الجنون فهذا هو الاثر الابتدائي
للوحي ثم بعد ذلك تلين والله سبحانه
وتعالى يذكر نموذجا من هذا كلما يقرا صاحب
القران قرانه
ويتدبر فالله عز وجل يقول تخشى عر منه
جلود الذين يخشون ربهم ثم تلين جلودهم
وقلوبهم ففي بادئ الامر يكون هذا الامر
هذا بمنزله الزبد وهذا الزبد وان انتفخ
وتعاظم في عين الناظر الا انه مظهر سرعان
ما يزول وكذلك
الباطل وكذلك ما يكون
حين اشتداد نار الصائغ
والكير على المعدن
النفيس وهو الابتلاء على
مؤمن المؤمن مبتلى لا محاله يقول تعالى
ولنبلونكم بشيء من الخوف والجوع ونقص من
الاموال والانفس والثمرات وبشر
الصابرين الذين اذا اصابتهم مصيبه قالوا
انا لله وانا اليه
راجعون اولئك عليهم صلوات من ربهم ورحمه
واولئك هم
المهتدون فهذا
الابتلاء هو كالكير على المعدن
النفيس لا يده
تهي لانه
مدب
لتشي لس ابتلاء
عشوائي الله ع وجل لا الله نف
وسعها من من الطاعه وكذلك من الابتلاء
قدرا وشرعا سبحانه وتعالى هذا امر مدبر
الانسان مقسوم له من الابتلاء
ما يطهره ولا
يكسره ولا يفلل له
عزمه
ف قوله تعالى زبد مثله يشبهه وهذا الزبد
الذي يكون اثر الابتلاء من الحزن والضيق
والتعب والى اخره الا ان هذه
الاشياء هذه هذا الشيء يكون ابنا
[Silence]
للحظتين كانما نشط من عقال
سبحان الله وينسى كل هذا
ولا ثم يتمتع بما امتعه الله سبحانه
وتعالى به ورزقه من الصفات الجميله ثم بعد
ذلك الجنه يقول صلى الله عليه وسلم لا
يزال البلاء بالمؤمن والمؤمن في نفسي
ومالي وولده حتى يلقى الله تعالى وليس
عليه خطيئه وجاء في الصحيح انه يؤتى باباس
اهل باباس اهل الارض من اهل
الجنه
فيغمس يغمس في في الجنه غمسه
واحده ثم يسال هل رايت بؤسا قط هل رايت
شده قط فيقول لا والله لم ارى بؤسا ولا
شده قط ينسى كل هذه لان هذ
زبت يذهب جفاء يقول
تعالى كذلك يضرب الله الحق
والباطل الحق
والباطل الصراع بين الحق
والباطل
سريع الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول بل نقذف
بالحق على الباطل فيدمغه فاذا هو زاهق
والذين
يفهمون دقائق اللغه العربيه يفهمون من هذه
الايه السرعه
يقول بل نقذف
بالحق على الباطل فيدمغه راسا ويدخل الى
الدماغ
ويدخل وينفذ الحق
الى الى مقاتل الباطل فاذا هو
زاهق لذلك
المعارك التي كانت تدور بين الصحابه الخلص
واعدائهم في زمن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
سريعه جدا في بضع دقائق
وتنتهي
لان الباطل لا يقوى على مواجهه
الحق
وانما يطول الصراع بين الحق والباطل اذا
كان الحق
دخيلا مدخولا فيه ما ليس منه من
الباطل يقول تعالى كذلك يضرب الله
الحق والباطل فاما الزبد الذي هو ممثل
بالباطل فيذهب
جفاءه واما ما ينفع
الناس من الحليه او المتاع او
الماء فيمكث في الارض
يبقى ويكتب الله سبحانه وتعالى له الخلود
على قدر خلود الارض لان كل ما في الارض
فانه ذاهب اييل الى الزوال عاجلا ام اجل
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول في حديث
انس عند
البخاري انه حق على الله الا يرتفع شيء من
الدنيا لوضعه
الله ولذلك لا نجد
مما يبقى من
الاسامي المتداوله على السن الناس عبر
التاريخ
المديد الا
اسامي الانبياء
والرسل تذهب اي بقعه في
الارض تسال من موسى من ابراهيم من عيسى من
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم وهم
يرفضونه ويق قال حتى لو كان غير
مؤمن ولهم الاف
السنين واما غيرهم من اصحاب الاموال
واصحاب الاتباع واصحاب ال فسرعان ما يذهب
ذكرهم يبقى 20 سنه 30 سنه ويموت ذكرهم وهم
احياء سبحان الله وكذلك
الملوك
وحتى اعداء الرسل اسمائهم تخلد في الارض
لعنا
لهم
لمجرد
مواجهتهم انبياء الله
بالسوء مثل فرعون الفراعنه كثر لم يحفظ
الا فرعون
واحد
كذلك النمرود
كذلك ابو جاهل وابو
لهب
لو ترك احدهم
يموت على ما كان عليه في الجاهليه يكون
ابا من اباء من سلسله
الاباء في تاريخ
ال في تاريخ هذه القبائل العربيه شيء عادي
اصحاب التواريخ متخصصين يحفظون هذه
الاسماء لا يكون الامر على ما هو عليه
اليوم يعلم هذه
الاسماء البر والفاجر
والمسلم وغير
المسلم لذلك قوله قول ابراهيم عليه السلام
واجعل لي لسان صدق في الاخرين ما هو لسان
الصدق الذكر الحسن في الارض يبقى يمكث
يمكث في الارض الذكر
الحسن
ف قوله تعالى واما ما ينفع الناس فيمكث في
الارض كذلك يضرب الله
الامثال
اخرج الامام مسلم في صحيحه
باسناده وكذلك البخاري فهو في الصحيحين من
حديث ابي موسى
الاشعري رضي الله عنه ان النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم جاء
بامثله تقارب هذا
المثال يقول صلى الله عليه وسلم مثل ما
بعثني الله به من الهدى
والعلم كمثل غيث اصاب
ارضا اصاب ارضا يعني ارض
واسعه مختلفه منها الطالع والنازل ومنها
الجافي ومنها
قال فكان منها طائفه طيبه قبلت الماء
وانبتت الكلا والعشب
الكثير الكلا
الذي هو مرعى الدواب والعشب الرطب من
الكلب فانتفعوا الناس هذه الطائفه من
الارض
اخذت العلم والهدى الذي ارسله الله هذا
الغيث
ف
انبتت الكلا والعشب الكثير فانتفع
الناس
قال وكان منها طائفه انما هي
اجادب امسكت الماء فانتفع
الناس
فسقوا
وشربوا وزرعوا
ورع
هذا مثال للذي يحفظ العلم وان كان لا يفقه
منه
كثيرا طائفه من الارض شربت الماء
و جاءت بالثمر وطائفه من الارض انما هي
قيعان القيعان من الارض المكان المنخفض
الجافي الذي يمسك
الماء يمسك الماء لغيره هو لا تتفع به
كثيرا ولكن يمسك الماء
لغيره ف في هذا
المثال عندنا
طائفه هم بمنزله
الفقهاء ياخذون
الوحي
يفهمون وياتون بنتائج الوحي التي تنعش
اجساد الناس
والدواب ويحيا بهم البلاد والعباد والشجر
والدواب وطائفه
اخرى ليس من
شانهم الفقه وانما من شانهم الحفظ يحفظون
العلم
لغيرهم يحافظون على الماء ويحافظون على
نقاوه الماء فيشرب
الناس
و تشرب الدواب فينتفع
بهم
قال وكان منها
طائفه
خبيثه انما
هي يقول صلى الله عليه وسلم لم
تنبتوا لم تنبتوا كلا ولا عشبا ولا امسكت
ماء ولا تمسك ماء فذلك ما بعثني الله به
من الهدى والعلم
فعلم فتعلم
وعلم ومثل من لم يرفع بذلك راسا ولم يقبل
هدى الله الذي ارسلت
به حديث
معروف
فالناس قسمه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم الى
ثلاثه
اقسام
قسم هم بمثابه الفقهاء وقسم هم بفا بمثابه
الحفاظ الذين يحفظون الدين وينقلونه الى
من هو افقه منه والثالث من لم يساهم لا
بهذا ولا بهذا ما
ساهم جاء
الغيث ولم ينبت لغيره ولم يمسك
لغيره هذا لم يرفع بذلك راسا ولم يقبل هدى
الله الذي بعثه الله تعالى به
ننتهي بقوله تعالى للذين استجابوا لربهم
الحسنى هذا
المثال يضرب الله الحق والباطل هنا المثال
الاول مثال اهل الخير اهل الحق مثال اهل
الباطل اهل الحق للذين استجابوا لربهم
الحسنى حسنى يعني منتهى
الحسن وهي الجنه وما فيها والذين لم
يستجيبوا له بل عمل وان كانوا يصدقون لكن
لا يذعنون لا
يتابعون لو ان لهم ما في الارض جميعا
ومثله معه لافتدوا به
فرضا ولكن هذا يوم لا ينفع مال ولا بنون
الا من اتى الله بقلب
سليم اولئك لهم سوء الحساب ما هو سوء
الحساب سوء
الحساب لا
تقبل منه الاعمال لانها غير مبنيه على
الايمان وعلى التقوى
وعلى
الاخلاص
ويؤاخذ بكل صغيره
وكبيره نسال الله
العافيه
الانسان حينما يحاسبه
الله اما ان يحاسب حساب
سيئا واما ان يحاسب حسابا
يسيرا حساب
اليسير هو ان يتجاوز له عن كثير
من يعني
سقطاته وهذا مفتاحه ان يكون متجاوزا عن
الناس
و الحساب العسير اسال الله العافيه
ولا يتجاوز ولا يسامح الشخص بصغيره ولا
بكبيره واخذ على كل شيء فلذلك يقول
العلماء المحاسب بين يدي الله فهو
بين فضل الله وعدل الله بين فضل الله وعدل
الله اما ان يح حاسبه الله بفضله فيعفو
ويتقبل القليل وياج الكثير ويتجاوز عن
الكثير واما بالعدل يؤاخذ بكل صغيره
وكبيره ومن عامله الله بعدله هلك يقينا
هلك كما يقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في
حديث عائشه في
الصحيحين من نوقش الحساب
عذب
من نوقش
الحساب
عذب نكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم صلى الله
وسلم على نبينا
محمد ي 17
18 سوره
الرعد الله سبحانه
وتعال
‏he tells
us that he is the one who sent down from
the heavens from
above a
strong
rain and
each ‏turn into aam asam forms we begin
to see a level
ofam which collects on to and at the
sides and on the banks
ofam that's the first
example he gives us the second
example he says and similar to
that a that is sar to though process is
very different
‏is the which rises
at metals when they are
melted when they are melted and when
they are refined we take
hard metals out of the earth we have to
refine them we have to purify how do we
purify any kind of precious metal from
gold to steel ‏ir
wefy harsh cr mets we purify them with
heat so the first example he
gave is the example of a stream that
carries on top of it a level of
foam second example he gives us is aam
which look
similar of the first but cause is very
different ‏the first is because of water
the second is a result of incredible
heat which ised to a base metal pure
metal to pufy a
metal or you know some kind of
element so we see that this
cols the first ex ex ration upon heart
heart
‏it is a difficult process because the
heart has in it has in it
desion and
soel قران is revealed and comes upon the
heart and is understood and is taken
into the
heart it develops into aam if it is if
the heart is exposed long enough now
that
‏will upset whatever is in the flo of
that it will upset it and it will take
it and loosen it and push it to the top
and we will start to see it in the form
of a
that looks very dirty and can collect
and become very big and look almost like
it's going to cover the stream entirely
at some point but
‏this is just an
illusion has no
integrity it has no reality to it just
something that looks big look scary but
it is really
harmless and it is necessary in the
process this is that of
fal
the
‏fals that comes and shows up
and it expands and it look big and looks
almost falsehood is
win but
falsehood is just illusion people have
fallen
for and is quickly
discal
‏we look at the people of fals that been
preserved on earth their
remem their mention their
name we see that they only been
remembered because of their interaction
their negative interaction with with
truth for instance the pha of
moses first of alloh
is a position
‏a title not even name name
was people don't know
name all we know about him are the bad
things that he did
why because that was the chose take
regard عليه
السلام and the only reas we
remember
عل l in an of time some deep in some
research
however مو ع ابراهيم عليه
السلام
‏ind tri from humanity and been the hs
of years they will know musa عليه السلام
they will the name whether they believe
in or not every knows their name why is
that the reason for
that الله سبحانه وتالى
made ‏seems it it will last but it
doesn't it's only good that which
benefits people remains in the earth as
we will hear he mentions that foam is
reminiscent of another foam which forms
but it's cause is that of the heat of
fire and the purging that takes place in
precious
metals likees
الله
‏tru and
fal gives the parable of truth and fal
as for the it is quickly discarded and
as for that which is of consequence to
to humanity and to the people it remains
in the earth remains in the
world likewise does allah give examples
and parables so we see here
that that which benefits people that
which is
‏of consequence to
life even though it may be down and out
but will always eventually
be the winner truth will always pril
over fals the darkness will never compl
eradicate the
light and hope will always be fulfilled
in some
way and so الله سبحانه
وتالى
tru people
thee people
that
he for those
who resp the call
lord parad
all ‏and they refuse meaning they refuse
to acknowledge or they refuse
to سبحانه
وتالى his call if they had at their
disposal all of the earth
riches
and another earth riches along with
‏they would be willing to give that rans
for themselves on the day of judgment of
course it will not be accepted from them
because that was first of all it's not
appropriate
‏and riches
never just a small
portion that a person is
required he says for those types of
people is the worst of judgement and
there will be the h fire and it is the
wor of
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد